and people asked me about what
opportunities you d see in the world I'd
say tunnels can someone please build
tunnels so after four or five years of
begging people to build tunnels and
still no tunnels I was like okay I
wonder will the tunnel it sounds
ridiculous but I genuinely believe it to
get from the time of getting fired -
getting to 80 employees in 36 millions
and sales literally not one vacation
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message be a doer over to you
Elon Musk also if you want to hear what
Elon Musk and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series I think I feel feel
fear quite strongly so it's not as
though I just have the absence of fear
I've I feel it quite strongly but there
are times when something is important
enough you believe it enough that you do
you do it in spite of fear every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a 30
second to five-minute video for free
every morning to help you build
unstoppable confidence the link is in
the description below
remember when you first told me that you
were thinking about tunnels and I must
tell you about that the years ago okay
it's like a long time ago like I thought
you're joking yeah it was always joking
but it's not because of some epiphany
that I had one day driving on the 405
that's how it gets called translates and
I was talking four tunnels for years and
years for probably five years or four
years at least whenever I'd give a talk
and people would ask me about what
opportunities you d see in the world I'd
say tunnels can someone please build
tunnels so after four or five years of
begging people to build tunnels and
still no tunnels I was like okay I wanna
build a tunnel like maybe a missing
something here so yes I was like
basically talking fuels IRA's own
funnels for it for several years and
then said well let's find out what it
takes to build a tunnel and you know so
started digging a tunnel I wanted to
start the tunnel from where I could see
it from my office that SpaceX it so
stuff I said well let's just cobble for
part of the parking lot across the road
so I can see if it's if anything's
happening or not and then we named our
first boring machine Godot because I
kept waiting for it no it came
finally did and and regret it going and
never making good progress entrepreneurs
are doers we find what is wrong with the
world we see problems we see people
complaining and we turn it into
something amazing that's what we do
that's why I love entrepreneurs we don't
just sit around and accept the status
quo we get frustrated with the status
quo and we do something about it I look
at this YouTube channel as a perfect
example I was sitting there wishing that
I could be around more successful people
like Elon Musk on a regular basis and
Elon Musk was a perfect example because
I would have to watch 20 30 40 hours of
footage to get the nuggets out that I
really wanted to get out one because
Elon talks about a lot of things that
didn't interest me and gets asked
questions that weren't amazing all the
time by interviewers and - because not
everybody is a fantastic public speaker
Eric Thomas can get you excited about
anything about brushing your teeth
they'll get you fired up to do it gotta
brush your teeth you know like you'll
get you fired up Elon is not the
greatest public speaker and so there's
there's Clips there's moments there's
these you know 15 minutes out of out of
20 hours that you can really pull out
and say that's the best stuff I wish
somebody had done it right I didn't want
to have to create my channel I wanted to
be a consumer of it but nobody else did
it so this is a solution I'm gonna go
off and do it I think about the same
thing for my new 254 series I've been
talking about for years how I think your
environment matters your routine matters
what you do on a daily basis matters if
you're around successful people on a
regular basis you will become more
successful your mindset will shift what
you tolerate what you accept your
standards will shift and so my new 254
series is around giving people that a
video every single day for the next 254
days they're on different topics they
want to let with this confidence when I
say at a sound to myself like a slimy
snake oil salesman that all you have to
do is watch it and you will change it
sounds ridiculous but I genuinely
believe it that if you watched a video
of people being confident and talking
about confidence from these people that
you look up to and respect and they've
had massive success for the next two
hundred fifty four days and you're not
doing anything else while you're doing
it you're not watching your phone you're
not taking notes on something else
you're not daydreaming you're sitting
there with
that you get an energy transfer from
them much more important than here are
the seven ways to become more confident
that if you are round confident people
you will become more confident and so
that's my goal it takes up to two
hundred fifty four days to build a new
habit and so I will be with you every
step of the way and in recognizing that
and talking about it nobody has built it
and so I'm building it we built our
first one to 54 confidence you can get
it for free in the description below I
want to do tons of these I want to do it
around different industries I wanna do
it for inventors I'm gonna do for
athletes I'm gonna do it for musicians
I'm gonna do it for video producers I'm
gonna do for writers I want to cover
different topics like self-love and
dealing with haters and deal with
judgment all of this stuff are all
separate to 54s and I'm building it and
I'm super excited about it because I'm a
doer and so are you and that's why I
love entrepreneurs and so I want to give
you some practical advice three
suggestions three ways to take those
ideas and do something about it number
one what's on your I wish list think
about what do you say I wish I wish this
existed I wish somebody came up with a
solution to that right for me
I wish somebody made these videos I wish
somebody made a daily series that became
a 2:54 confidence I wish I wish I wish
what do you find yourself saying I wish
to a lot we had to write down a list I
wish dr. thought like what would be on
that list the things that you wish could
happen then it's changing the mindset to
say I'm going to make that thing happen
number two what are the people around
you complain about if you don't have
anything big on your I wish list you're
still trying to figure out what your
opportunity is think about the people
around you what are they complaining
about what is so frustrating for them
because making money in business is
about providing value the more you
provide value the more you help people
the more money you will make and so by
looking at the people around you saying
all these people are really complaining
about this thing they all they had there
I wish list they all have this same
problem if I solved it they would pay me
for it and it's not just the people
around me there's a whole world that
people have that same issue so looking
at what the people around you a
complaint about is a great way to find
your next business idea
I know number three is just take a small
step whatever your big dream is whatever
you're on your I wish list is just
go out and do one thing you know I'm
looking at my youtube channel you might
think why it's too hard to make a
youtube channel like that I need a team
and I need I need lights and fancy
camera and all this stuff don't worry
about that just what's your first step
that could be what you build towards
what is your first step to getting
started
quick story when I was driving to Boston
I had my vlogging crew with me and Danny
is talking about how he wants to do a
feature-length movie and and he's never
done it and it's always been on his list
and just think about this story for the
last eight years like eight years dude
we got to do something like are you
gonna wait another eight years and
another eight years like when is this
thing actually gonna happen just don't
make it this big production because you
can't afford that now but how do you
shrink that down to five minutes take
that big idea of a two hour movie into
five minutes what does a five minute
movie look like for you he said well it
can't be done in five minutes and then
over the next 30 minutes we talked it
out and he figured out how to get it
done in five minutes and then he wrote a
script in the car ride on the way home
for what his five minute video would
look like and then he put a casting call
out for getting to the actors to come in
and play those different roles and we
figured out what the locations he could
use basically playing out the whole
thing net it's gonna take him about
three weeks of work two weeks of work
putting it all together and he has this
five minute film this thing that's
taking him eight years of thinking to
actually moving the needle forward and
taking some action on it so take that
equivalent in your own life and your own
business whatever your goal is you want
to make that that feature-length movie
right that that equivalent for you and
then shrink it down what does a five
minute version of it look like for you
your big goal what is a tiny little
version that looked like and then start
building momentum towards it some small
kind of action and if you can commit
other people to it you get momentum like
crazy so him just writing the script is
a good first step but him posting the
job ad and then people writing back to
him to say hey I'd like to play this
character hey I like to play that
character people are now responding to
him it forces extra momentum because
other people are involved so you have
your I wish list you have the complaints
from the people around you you have this
idea for what to do now take the first
small step to building it now I've got a
really special bonus clip for you but
before that question of the day I want
to know what is the thing that you've
been holding off what's your plan what's
that thing you've had in your head for
the past
eight years but haven't taken action on
it and today you're gonna release it
today today you're gonna actually do
something about it leave that down the
comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso and enjoy the bonus clip
[Music]
see the idea of being entrepreneurs or
being our own bosses are building their
own empires this thing that you know you
need investments you need all these
people move lip flip right look if this
sock costs $5 to make we sell it for $20
you make $15 flip with rocking with you
know I was trying to give a Rakhi for a
long time she's Spanish and you know
Puerto Rican girls they can't bring
black boys home old school you know I'm
saying right
so it took a minute you know saying for
and she was throwing me curveballs left
and right and so one of her curveballs
was you know I see you put all these
other people on you know I see you make
all these other people's dreams come
true but you like to make movies I can't
get with you unless you stand behind
what you love and I was like all right
you know I had to you know I mean she
called me out you know I'm saying so it
was like you know I can't have my woman
or girl I want to be my woman calling me
out but also it made perfect sense it
was true
I was unconsciously probably standing
behind other people instead of standing
behind myself all I do is get somebody
and tell them how to get it and you know
make the things that are wrong right but
if I can make the things that are wrong
right for somebody else why not sell me
you know understand like even down to
the diabetes I'm like yo yeah we do a
whole network on diabetes or something
that's usually considered a weakness I'd
prefer to turn it into a strength it's
about me understand what I'm saying
working at your business software it
actually went really good for a while
because I I didn't have a tech
background and so it gave me the
opportunity to teach myself and I found
out that I like tech you know which was
shocking to me and so I would sit in
there and use the computers and teach
myself all the software from way back
when the word stars the word perfect the
you know the peach tree software is for
those of us that go way back when and
one day and in mind you I'm sleep I'm
living in a three bedroom apartment with
six guys six 23 24 year old guys however
nasty you think it is it was worse
I didn't have a closet I didn't have a
drawer I had a pile and I wear contacts
I wore contacts oh but I wear my classes
at night and I didn't have any money so
I broke my classes that I would hit them
up and they'd tear apart hi one piece
here one piece there oh it was an
adventure but um yeah but so one day I'm
living in this [ __ ] and I get the
opportunity to close a big deal and it
was going to be $1500 Commission to me
yes sir let's go and I call my boss a
guy named Michael Hugh Mickey and I said
Michael I've got this deal and part of
my job responsibilities were sweeping
the floor it was a retail store sweeping
the floor making sure the windows were
clean and opening up and I've got you
know one of my fellow employees all set
to do all that I call him up and said
Michael it's a $15,000 sale I but I need
to go pick it up before before work I
won't be there to open things up he goes
no I need you to open up the store I'm
like I got it conferred and I make the
executive decision that I'm gonna go
pick up the check and I'm gonna hand
them the check and he's going to forget
all about it and we're all gonna be
friends and I'll make my commission
fired me for disobeying him I haven't
seen him since but I was probably the
best thing that could have happened yeah
right now but in any event um but it
made me realize that I need to work to
myself again you know that I'm an
entrepreneur at heart and so I just
don't know it's not just is what it is
and and so I couldn't take the $1,500
Commission it was his company was his
sale and and so I found another customer
that I had been talking to a prospect a
company called architectural lighting
and Here I am sleeping in the [ __ ]
with no job and desperate um but I
convinced this this company
architectural lighting there was a piece
of software that I wanted to sell them
for five hundred bucks and I told them
it cost me 250 and that I would make it
work and train them
support them if they would loan me the
250 to buy the software upfront and if
it didn't work for whatever reason I've
walked their dogs clean their cars you
know scrub their toilets whatever it
took to pay them back and fortunately it
worked and that led to another customers
led to another customer that was a
company called micro solutions over the
next seven years I didn't take a
vacation taught myself out a program
taught myself you know more about
technology that of networking then I
thought I would ever know and we grew to
you know give or take 36 million in
sales 80 employees and I sold it back
you know 1990 I guess time flies for six
million dollars but for you know a
twenty nine thirty year old kid that was
real money and and so um then it's big
money and not that it's not now it
really is but it's just but it to get
from the time of getting fired to
getting to 80 employees in 36 million in
sales literally not one vacation
altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video